transcriptomics three is of course
dedicated to advanced methods of
analysis that will allow us to find
meaningful patterns in data especially
complex patterns that are present in big
datasets in this video we will turn our
attention to supervised machine learning
classification and feature selection in
the transcriptomics 3 course we are
learning about machine learning for
transcriptomic data as we've already
discussed machine learning can be
separated into two main categories of
methods the first of which is
unsupervised machine learning which
focuses on the detection of patterns and
data the main idea here is to apply
techniques that are automated and rely
on various assumptions about data in
order to learn from it the second main
category is supervised machine learning
these methods rely on the availability
of training data which has been labeled
once the data set of labelled data has
been accumulated it can be used to train
a model that will be able to apply this
knowledge to analyze new data for
example by predicting its class large
RNA seek data collections provide us
with the opportunity to discover signals
and gene expression that might not be
apparent with smaller sample sizes such
as prognostic indicators or predictive
factors this is especially the case for
subsets of patients however discerning
this signal in such large data sets
frequently relies on the application of
machine learning algorithms to identify
relationships and high dimensional data
or to cope with computational
complexities these approaches often
construct a model that capture relevant
features of a data set the model can be
used to make predictions about new data
such as how well a patient will respond
to a particular treatment or whether
their cancer is likely to recur
therefore the model is usually
constructed using a large and diverse
data set which will then be applied to
incoming cases to make predictions
them in this video we're going to be
learning about such methods that will
explain how classification as well as
feature selection works supervised
machine learning takes place in data
that has to be labeled and typically
this is done by people in biomedical
projects this could be clinical data or
some other type of phenotypic data this
label data is use the trainer model and
the model will be tested on a test data
set this data set will include examples
of what is in the training data the
methods vary as do the principles that
we'll be using to build the model but
for now we can refer to them as a black
box the method we'll essentially learn
from the differences between various
classes that are present in the training
data set
once the learning has been established
you'll have a model or a template that
can be applied to new datasets new data
will have to be assigned with a class
that is present in the training data set
so if something doesn't fit such as the
stars on the bottom right of this screen
model accuracy will be reduced the
output of a classification algorithm
includes predicted classes for each
object or sample that's found in the
data some algorithms such as random
forests also evaluate how accurate and
stable the prediction is evaluating
which features if taken out will be the
most significant for the accuracy of the
prediction to illustrate this concept
simply we can look at the classification
of images we train the model by showing
it images of cats and dogs and then
testing that prediction on other
variations of cat and dog images but
instead of cats and dogs we have gene
expression to train the model we'll have
to label the data by using phenotypic
information such as cancer stage or
subtype of risk factor and the training
data we will have a special row that we
will call class and it will contain
labels for each of the samples genes and
the machine learning language are going
to be
features and samples are called objects
the test dataset will not have the
classroom it will only contain genes
sample names as well as levels of
expression one such algorithm is called
binary decision trees their output looks
similar to hierarchical clustering with
each tree being created by thresholds
and rules binary means the branch can
either be yes or no if the expression of
a genes is higher than X the classes
will separate the algorithm will
continue until it has effectively
separated all the samples into some
group if we use less genes in the
training data set we will get different
results because the data set can be
dealt with differently also binary
decision trees are initiated with random
started so the genes selected in this
procedure can change from time to time
here we see the cell line data separated
into three groups luminal basil and
Cloudland low with two genes random
forests uses multiple instances of these
decision trees that are applied to
portions of the data one at a time after
the analysis the tree predictions are
analyzed the majority voting is accepted
the algorithm is useful for more complex
patterns where smoother borders between
classes are needed it also gives an
output of most significant features for
classification linear discriminant
analysis or Lda is a generalization of
Fisher's linear discriminant which is a
method that's used in statistics pattern
recognition and machine learning this
method is used to find a linear
combination of features they
characterize or separate two or more
classes of objects or events the
resulting combination may be used as a
classifier or for dimensionality
reduction before later types of
classification LD a is closely related
to analysis of variance as well as
regression analysis which also attempt
to express one dependent variable as a
linear combination of other
features and measurements however
analysis of variance uses categorical
independent variables and the continuous
dependent variable whereas discriminant
alysus has continuous independent
variables and a categorical dependent
variable ali-a is also closely related
to principal component analysis which is
also called PCA as well as factor
regression analysis and that they both
look for linear combinations of
variables which best explain the data
by contrast PCA does not take into
account any of the differences in class
in factor analysis builds two feature
combinations based on differences rather
than the similarities what's important
to remember here is that Lda assumes
that the data is normally distributed
within each class so preparing the data
before running the analysis is going to
be an essential step wise Lda makes it
possible to automatically select those
features in your data that are most
useful or most relevant for the problem
that you're working on this is a process
called feature selection feature
selection is different from
dimensionality reduction although both
methods seek to reduce the number of
attributes in the dataset a
dimensionality reduction method does so
by creating new combinations of
attributes feature selection methods
include as well as exclude the
attributes that are present in the data
without actually changing them stepwise
linear discriminant analysis is used to
find a subset of the provided features
that optimally separate the classes that
are inherent in the data in this
procedure the discriminant model is
built iteratively starting with an empty
set of features ali-a classification is
evaluated on each feature and the
feature resulting in the highest
accuracy is added to the optimal feature
set other features are added to the set
in the order of maximum improvement of
accuracy until no significant
improvement is provided by further
features this is called a forward
selection procedure where one adds
features to the model one at a time at
each step each feature that is not
already in the model is tested for
inclusion
the most significant of these features
is added to the model so long as its
p-values below some of the preset levels
for instance this could be 0.05 this
column fresh hold is set by the new Vogt
parameter the input files are going to
be the same as for the LDA pipeline for
our expression data which contain
expression levels for almost 7,000 genes
we set this value to be zero point zero
zero zero five in the results of the
pipeline we found that it selected just
nine genes but they provided a perfect
classification for the training set
another important method we will talk
about a support vector machines this
algorithm differs from other
classification methods because it is
optimal to find the boundary of the
class and uses a feature space
transformation with a kernel function
that makes separation more efficient for
example a circular class border can be
achieved by a straight hyperplane if the
space was curved in such a way that the
classes are cut by it with a decision
surface the original SVM algorithm was
invented by vladimir vapnik and alexei
Shyvana kiss in 1963 vapnik suggested a
way to create nonlinear classifiers by
applying the kernel trick to a maximum
margin hyperplane
the current standard incarnation of SVM
using soft margins was proposed by
Corina Cortez and Babinec in 1993 and
published in 1995 this idea of support
vector machines is to not the training
data into a higher dimensional space
feature via fee and construct a
separating hyperplanes maximal margin
there this trick helps to find efficient
ways of separating classes while dealing
with messy data that cannot be separated
by linear boundaries as a result the
transformation creates a new function
for distance in the new space an SVM
model is a representation of the
examples as points in space and their
map so that the examples of the separate
categories
are divided by the clear gap this is why
possible new examples have been going to
be mapped into some space and predicted
belong to a category based on which side
of the gap they follow during this
prediction stage the SVM algorithm will
measure distance of a new object in the
kernel space to the nearest
representative in the training data SVM
stands for support vector machine this
is an efficient classifier that can deal
with complex separation between classes
however it could have trouble working
with too many features the input is
trained and test data and the output is
a predicted class with a guru CIL's for
a prediction there are many
considerations that should be made for
supervised analysis first we should fit
our classifier on a training set and
predict the classes on the test set we
also have to determine if it's possible
to tune 7000 coefficients by 52 samples
some of the algorithms do feature
selection such as s WL VA and random
forests however other algorithms won't
work if the number of features is in
great access to the number of samples
and then there's the curse of
dimensionality these methods are
commonly used in a variety of biomedical
research as well as clinical projects
for large datasets are beginning to be
more and more available these include
patient stratification disease
classification and diagnostics
identification of potential responders
of therapies mechanisms of disease onset
and progression and then on the form of
biotech side there's biomarker discovery
detection of toxicity of the in vitro
stage the analysis of molecular
mechanisms of drug action which is also
known as target discovery and then drug
repurposing and repositioning